[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm wrecked what
just happened something in your throat I
I'm I'm I'm I'm battling uh I'm fighting
off it's not covered just so you know
there's a there's like a there's a very
mild cold that's going through my
household and I and I'm like in day
three of fighting it and this is as bad
as it's gotten it's like every once in a
while just a slight
scratching my throat well I don't want
to get it dude because it already
happens in your family is what Christy
told me because I we're Chris and I have
a romantic getaway this weekend and I
don't want to be hacking and thinking
about the fact that you gave me
something so don't do this even if it is
worst all it got to for Shepard was like
a sore throat for a day and then went
away so
and I'm tougher than he is
and so the worst that it's gotten for me
is this slight
impacting my speech so as long as you
can still
if your voice cracks a little bit when
you're making love to your wife I think
that that's I think that's totally
accept acceptable acceptable yeah it's
just it's just kind of part of the
Reckless abandon of the of the weekend
uh one day Shepard is going to be
stronger than you and it's going to
happen a lot quicker than you think
and I'm link
this week at the round table of dim
lighting we're talking about your most
disturbing slash spooky experiences
because that's the prompt that we put
out
when we tweeted we want to hear about
your most disturbing spooky experiences
give us a call and share your story at
1-888 earpod one and here we are
read about reading we're listening to
these and
um you can also use hashtag your
biscuits and we will read the stuff that
you send so one of the more disturbing
things that has happened to me in the
past five minutes is seeing you sit down
with a Starbuck
when just so you know when you have one
serving of a Starbucks thing is a
Starbucks okay okay all right so you
have a Starbucks and the name on it is
Blake which is just so much money I mean
it's just amazing what now what did did
you say link I said link
I mean this is such a this is such a
Trope I mean but it's amazing to me like
like blink black
I mean they it doesn't really matter
I was in the drive-through oh it wasn't
like that yeah I really don't care but
they're going to call out Blake you
would never go to that I would never go
to yes I would
I'm going to well if they said Blake
you'd go up and you'd be like uh
link oh well I guess Blazer Blake here
because Lily works at a uh a Starbucks
now
I'm very you know I'm totally on the
employers
employees side of this
my feelings aren't hurt I think the
thing that's more disturbing than you
being called Blake is the fact that you
have a Starbucks and like you don't
you're so routine oriented that anytime
anybody around here is like Hey we're
getting Starbucks you're like no thanks
like yeah you NE so what series of
events led you to going to Starbucks and
going through the drive-through and
getting a coffee for Blake you know like
how did this happen I feel very seen
right now thank you I've never seen you
provide these except for like a like a a
set on something we're working on I
passed by the Starbucks and there's a
just line going to that drive-through
and I just always look at it with this
stain because it's clogging up my exit
artery to get to work and I'm never
getting in that line for the first time
ever today I got in that line I was I
hit it hit snooze
you know we had a dinner last night
I was there gosh I I just I was telling
you I ate too much talk about a Horror
Story disturbing and spooky experience
just too much decadent sauciness you
didn't even you you're the only one who
took him a doggy bag did you see first
of all this place served food at least
your food and my food were served in a
dog bowl yeah it was like like if you're
gonna get a bowl outside like a like a
large dog like we're talking German
Shepherd and up that was what we were
served in yeah and
mine I mean you know who I am I saw a
lobster risotto on the menu and I was
like check please or whatever yes yes
please and I love the fact that you and
Christy play this game where it's like
you know what it like what she knew what
I was gonna she always knows what you're
gonna order because she almost what she
almost got it uh and it had one pound of
lobster in it
I ate every damn bit of it I got this
shrimp just like a dog shrimp Alfredo
penne pasta it was amazing but yeah I I
got to a point where I was just eating
the shrimps yeah so much but we have so
many appetizers what I'm saying was I
felt kind of bad going to sleep and then
I like felt bad when I woke up it was
like it was a it was a gut hangover yeah
and so I just kept hitting snooze I did
not want to try to like I didn't want to
I didn't want my body to go upright
and so that set me on a path of like
being kind of in a tizzy because I'm up
against getting dropping Lando off at a
specific time I can't actually be late
for that because he can't stand it if
I'm if I drop him off late so then I I
had made my smoothie at the last second
and I and I I did decide to eat my
smoothie even though no part of me
wanted to was it a rushed smoothie it
was a rush and I didn't eat it with a
spoon I made a coffee at the same time I
still ate it with a spoon and
so you ate up I was in a real hurry in a
rush with a spoon yeah yeah I'm really
glad I wasn't there for that
it just I it just makes me feel like
there's there's still some sanity in my
life you know how great that I you do
know how gravity and throats work right
it's like liquids throats and gravity
a science project by reply the link will
know how to drink yeah it does say a lot
like as in a hurry as I was I was still
gonna do that and but I made my coffee
in parallel as opposed to what I
normally do which is eat my smoothie out
of my coffee mug after I've finished my
coffee an hour earlier
really yeah I drink my coffee right when
I get up and then I go get ready and
then I come back down and I make my
smoothie and I pour it in your whole
smoothie fits in your coffee cup no I
have to pour it twice
so there's less there's so you have less
to clean up yeah you want your coffee to
taste you want your smoothie to tastes a
little bit there's less to clean up
um I had to make my coffee in parallel
this morning with my smoothie that went
into a cup
and then I just ran out the door and I
forgot my coffee because I usually have
drunk my coffee earlier I never take a
coffee in the car okay what's the over
under on you having your wallet right
now I'm gonna say that there is a 75
chance you do not have your I have my
wallet you do have your wallet how did
that happen because when we drove home
last night I took it out of my pocket
and I put it in the console oh so it was
in your car I keep my wallet in my car
yes that's where I keep it so whenever
we go somewhere in your car that's why I
never have my wallet so somebody steals
your car they can also steal your
identity just good good thing to note
yep and I get a little two for one and I
usually leave my keys in my car too
right so it's like I just make it in
your house it's just like
yeah they can just assume your life and
there's a mask of me if you stand in the
glove box car there's like a very
realistic mask of my face but you're
gonna have to drink that damn smoothie
every morning with a spoon eat it with
this right like that as long as you do
that my family will not notice the
difference like kill me put on my mask
just don't ever think about drinking a
smoothie without a spoon and and uh you
know what you'll you'll be living the
life man because I have quite a life
I haven't been able to calibrate my life
since I'm trying once again with the
thing I tried last year
where I'm eating in a in a restricted
window from like noon to 8 P.M right and
and so not eating in the morning means
I'm not getting my smoothie in the
morning and I believe that the Smoothie
had a bunch of nutrients that now I'm
probably not getting from other meals
that's got to become your lunch or your
dinner and so
I'm just I'm a little bit torn that's
why I forced myself to eat the Smoothie
this morning plus there's like I put so
much flaxseed in that thing it's the
only thing that like I count on that to
keep me regular I don't want to go there
but
yeah I don't know I haven't I haven't
been missing out you're missing out dude
well I need to get some of that I had
some of that green stuff we don't have a
sponsor like everyone is sponsored by
athletic greens maybe we should be so I
but I use something else other than
athletic greens uh that is also not a
sponsor but I ran out of it but it's
essentially like powder that I think
just makes you feel like a super person
but I ran out of that so maybe that's
why I got a little scratchy throat you
talking about kachava no I'm talking
about what I use green
similar stuff they should be a sponsor
yeah we need to get one of these
sponsors one of these one of these green
sponsors and I'll start doing it again I
want to get in to a voicemail do you
yeah
all right before you play it
I think we need to take the uh Coast to
Coast approach here which is you don't
like the like the Reddit approach
which I'm not a huge fan of Reddit but
the thing I do like about Reddit is when
people tell a story
you're not really supposed to question
whether or not they're lying yeah so
we're what's the point of that we're
choosing to believe that all these
things happen to you and we're not going
to try to poke hoes into hoes we're not
going to poke hoes or holes into your
story
yeah what's it what's a hole in hose
called
oh
a ho ho it's for the dirt to go through
you know like um I don't know I'll play
it you know like a rip in pantyhose
that's all I'm talking about here
hey renley so the creepiest thing that
ever happened to me uh I lived in a
haunted house uh when I was in high
school and I would see this little girl
uh pretty much all the time and a bunch
of my family members saw her my friends
are
um but the creepiest thing that happened
is we were outside watching a tornado
and uh I came back inside
I looked down the hall and the squirrel
is walking down the hall and she's
probably three foot three and a half
foot tall and as she gets closer I can I
I realize that she doesn't have a face
and she floats up to me and floats right
through me
and disappeared and that's probably the
creepiest thing that I've ever
experienced
man I got a little bit
the cackles
stood up what is that what happens your
cockles cockles no one cockle's fine uh
I think it's cockles my cockle did not
respond
um
my cackles
what I mean the fact that halfway
through this story it's about a there's
a tornado in it and it's not the story
is not even about the tornado yeah he's
watching the tornado we were yeah we got
this haunted house with the with the
with a little woman in it
turns out to be faceless we were outside
watching a tornado once like hey I feel
you I I feel that like if a tornado was
coming up I think I would really want to
watch it but
and then just as long as I know where
I'm going to run if you've got the a
basement of sorts
but then you come back inside this is
this is what we talked about last week
man man you got the you got the little
woman or the girl because this is a this
is a common story a faceless little girl
this is a common thing
um where people see
a person of a certain type right
uh even down there at the uh at the
the hotel in Chester Arkansas that are
good friends Lance and Lacey run there's
a story of a guy who died there and
there's like I don't know all the
details but multiple people will see
that guy right and and so of course
there's the multiple people thing that's
well there's a you know about
suggestibility or power suggestion if
like okay if I'm gonna season but again
I I
choose to this happens so often I choose
to believe that people are seeing they
are seeing something that is coming
across to them like they're seeing
a little girl without a face in in this
sense floating through him what would
you do I mean I just don't
I don't think I could stand there and
let a ghost fly through me because right
before she floats through me she's
floating right up to me you know that's
a flea situation
I mean or play dead or something you
know it's like I've never had any any
experience like this but I just do you I
don't know what I would do do you want
to have no no well to me I'm of two
minds one is of course I don't want to
be scared I kind of do actually
but it's more
seeing that would be a super cool thing
and it would
it would it would change my world view
because my world view right now is that
I just don't I
something must be going on but I just
really doubt that it is ghosts or
whatever I heard somebody talking about
uh that these paranormal things are
related to Echoes In Time
uh we don't understand everything there
is about the nature of time and space
right okay like every you know I know I
don't and I I yeah I mean I've read some
popular science books where they try to
explain it to people like me who don't
are not studied but the idea of
essentially
everything that's ever happened is
always happening or so you're basically
like at times you're running into other
things that have happened in that space
so it isn't necessarily like
this little girl died her soul remained
around and she's haunting the house
I mean maybe again I don't I don't know
but what would you do in that scenario
now I think it is important to know that
like they felt like she was there
this wasn't the first experience
a tornado is coming by the way
um
you know I I just can't at a certain
point you're like yeah there's a there's
a girl here
we just can't she we live with her you
know she just floated through me
don't have a face
at a certain point you just kind of like
have to live with it I guess but I just
don't has anybody ever been beat up I
would be cat I would run
but why has anybody ever been killed by
a ghost
I don't I don't know okay wait okay oh
Ryan said we've got we've got a story
okay oh gosh we got someone who died
which number
20. oh number 20. all right well not
died but I mean all right let's listen
to number 20 then hi my name is Vivi and
I'm a big fan
um so this actually happened to my mom
uh but me and my dad were there to
witness it we were moving out of this
totally creepy house uh we didn't even
last there six months it was so creepy
um
we one of these creepy things we would
he we would uh here were these footsteps
that would just run across the hallway
upstairs it was just like these noises
and uh at the time we just convinced
ourselves that it was our cat I think we
were in denial we really wanted to
believe it was like it was just the cat
um anyway we were moving out me and my
dad left we came back my mom was uh
still at the old house and when we came
back we hear this loud toe curling
scream come from upstairs me and my dad
freak out we run upstairs where we find
my mom lying on the ground crying and
praying we asked her what the heck
happened she tells us that she walked
into my bedroom where she just instantly
felt this like negative energy she felt
like she was just frozen she couldn't
move she suddenly felt like this heavy
feeling in her chest she couldn't
breathe
um she tried to pray and when she tried
to pray she felt something like grab her
and pull her down and just scratch her
whole body
um she looked up and she saw these uh
cracks starting to form in the ceiling
um and that really freaked me out
because I told my mom like I used to see
these cracks form in the ceiling I
didn't mention it before because I was a
teenager so I assumed that they would
assume the worst if I just you know oh
there's cracks forming in my ceiling
whatever
um so anyway
um we were like we need to get out of
here like we just we're just done like
let's just go I'm pretty sure we forgot
some stuff um as we were leaving and
walking out the door we hear these
footsteps upstairs
so yeah totally wasn't the cat um as we
were in the car my mom pulled up her
pants and she had these unexplained
scratch marks going down her legs
so yeah that's our scary story
good gracious they do attack and they
also really mess up your drywall
yeah man that's why you got to have them
popcorn ceilings in your haunted house
to cover up for the crap okay I have
yeah I have a physical reaction when I
hear these stories this I I get
like my look I go into completely denial
the hair stands up on my like I'm not
engaging the hair stands up on my uh
arms uh it's so cocky man
foreign
I you know what
I believe him you know it they they
don't seem
that just they just she seems so
level-headed you know
yeah man I mean if she was my doctor I
would I would take the prescriptions you
know I would trust this voice
two two many people who I trust have had
experiences that they can't explain that
I'm sure somebody's smarter than me
could explain why it was just their mind
playing tricks on them but I just you
know what I can't right but I just don't
I just don't think that's an adequate
explanation I think there's something
that we don't understand is happening
ah
I mean yeah so but what what would you
do because I've never lived in a haunted
house I've never had an experience like
this but there's been a few times when
I've been alone
um
in my own home
and I think maybe a couple of times when
I've been in like a house
alone that wasn't my own home
in that same feeling that I just got
when she was telling that story it'll
happen to me and I'll start freaking
myself out
it's all from anticipation and me
imagining what might happen but I've
never experienced anything I don't know
what I would do some people just are
like yeah we have this particular
presence in our house and it's and it's
weird and it's something we talk about
but
we don't feel like we should leave
I'd leave this situation
this is a little bit different when the
family is United and the mama's been
scratched when Mama gets scratched you
don't look back don't look back
you know talk talk about horror
scenarios I can't think of few that are
worse than if
um you don't vote and then things that
you wish didn't happen start happening
to uh to your local
State and national government right I
just want to remind you these midterm
elections are important
sometimes the things that you care about
that affect you on a local level
uh it just comes down to thousands if
not hundreds of votes
so we want to just
clarify that you have power you know as
if as an American I'm assuming you're
I'm speaking to the Americans right now
because we have midterm elections and we
want you to go to the website that we
have created vote likeabbeast.com so
that you can get in touch with the
issues and where you stand on them get
in touch with yourself and the issues
and then vote and the people and we've
made it very easy for you to check your
voting status and some states I think
you can register right up until election
day some states there's a deadline
depends on where you're at but uh you
can check that we got you back vote like
a beast.com
don't vote how we want you to vote but
vote how you want to vote and vote
um let's go to this one
hey Rhett and Link uh so I had a spooky
encounter when I was in high Square
College
um
I there was a music and arts building in
my college had a small reputation of
being haunted um
and I
was a bit of an insomniac so I did all
my practicing in the middle of the night
um so one like random like Thursday
night I
went to practice at around 2 am
and when I went up to the top floor
where all those practice rooms are for
macawanda
practice expecting it to be empty I
heard someone practicing piano
um and I thought okay I've got a fellow
friend Insomniac here but um
I got a little curious after I practiced
for a bit and they were still going so I
went over to see who it was and there's
nobody in the room and I
uh
sprinted out of the building and then
got over it and practiced there every
night for the rest of my college career
but it was still very terrifying so I
did not love that sprinted out of the
building yes right answer
coming back
every other time you wanted to practice
strange
but what application why does that have
to be the the answer the only thing this
ghost did was play piano
that's uh that's an olive branch okay
the you know that's the ghost saying
what was that did you hear that
what was that noise
my cat
I don't what I don't believe my uh you
talking about my stomach growing really
loudly right now yeah I don't think this
mic picked up on it maybe it did I don't
know it's pretty loud
it's that meal we ate last night is that
risotto trying to find his weight
um
risotto
I I don't know because
first of all totally get being scared I
would be scared I'm not saying that I
would do this but if there were a ghost
that was playing the piano in a room
and you knew that this piano was being
played
would be like whip out your phone
yeah that's what that's what you would
want
I think they know that I think they know
I think the Ghost Protocol is to not
isn't that like a mission impossible
Ghost Protocol yeah yeah yeah I think
the Ghost Protocol is to not let iPhones
catch catch you they know that that's
Android that's like the orientation like
the one it ghost orientation is like
people break out the phones you stop
playing the piano oh
okay but I don't know like what were
they trying to do
what are they trying to prove I I you
know again I'm trying not to pick it
apart like when I it makes me feel
better to pick it apart but we've we've
said we're not going to do that so now I
don't have anything to say I'm just
gonna play another one
hi I'm here to tell you my
my story
um this is also
basically the summer before seventh
grade my friends and I
um there were four of us we decided to
do a Ouija board at her grandmother's
house
um so there were four of us in the room
but only three of us went to the Ouija
board the fourth girl decided to just
text her mom and she was like oh they're
gonna do Ouija board and she goes oh
don't do it it was when I did it with my
friends we were about your age and it
was a horrible idea like we had to get a
priest to you know help us out and we're
like okay that's terrifying but whatever
we're still gonna do it so we put our
hands on it and it all starts moving and
we're like what's that what the heck I
got so what's going on
um and it gives us these random numbers
maybe a few letters uh so we asked her
to look it up because she was on her
phone anyways and we get um a highway
code in Portland and we're like okay
that is just random whatever it doesn't
matter
um but then her she tells her mom that
and her mom goes my friend who we are
trying to contact died in a car crash on
a highway in Portland OR it died on a
car crash in Portland and we're like
okay that's freaky like what
um
so later we get 923 the numbers
um and we're like okay what what does
that mean like we're thinking you know
93 maybe that was a license plate you
know blah blah blah she goes my friend
died on September 23rd and now we're
like freaking out we're like this is
crazy but we don't get anything after
that so you know this is August right
now we're like you need to look out for
September 23rd see if anything happens
you know something is going on and the
friend who hosted it on that day
September 23rd finds four dead birds in
her backyard and there are four people
in the room it's crazy it was crazy it
was crazy
so crazy
so that's it that's my spooky story hope
you enjoy If This Were A Movie I
wouldn't have ended there
you know they would have figured out a
way to like write the rest of the movie
four dead birds is not it does not make
an ending
um an ending does not make is what
you're trying to say Yes
um see
how do I not just say things like well
you know Ouija boards just like psychics
it's like first of all
it's cooperation of people
and then it's just numbers which like
fine just finding some random stuff and
then making a cleaning out of it
um but I'm not gonna go there it's
impossible not to again I want to go
there as well
I think one of the ironic things I
didn't go there is that we don't we did
not I just think this is an interesting
tidbit
when we were Christians
and believed
vehemently in the Supernatural and
believed that there was a war going now
we weren't charismatic we were you were
very reformed I was
pretty reformed and in that tradition
there's not a lot of talk of demons and
angels and stuff there's this belief
that they exist but they're not very
active or you know
so we tend to have
an almost naturalistic view of the
supernatural world even within the
Christian tradition it's kind of
fascinating and so any of this Ouija
board
I just was like this is just people
making connections I don't think that
the devil is wasting his time with Ouija
boards it just feels like a dumb
distraction is what I thought as a
Christian it's actually post
uh faith when I'm in this place where
I'm like listen I realize now how little
I I just had this very narrow slice of
of my interpretation of reality and now
I'm just like there's so many things
that I don't understand and so I
actually have more of an openness to
there being some legitimacy to these
people's experiences but still the
skeptic I mean goes to this place what
you're saying which is
you're going to get some numbers
everybody's moving it it's not like a
Ouija board doesn't work by you placing
the little glass on it and then
everybody stands back and it moves on
its own like Hannah goes through that
too a can of demon do that so there's
always these little things that like oh
well people are moving it around
um I think it would like if I found out
that my my kids
were at a slumber party and they were
like doing this a Ouija board
I I mean I think my first thing would be
like oh
was it was it scary was it fun you know
I would interact with it like a game
like the board game that it sold as you
know it's in Walmart yeah probably in
Walmart
um
but you know going back to the like the
our world view and how it impacted
things and it just kind of like we just
weren't interested in it I think it's
because
we actually did believe that we were we
had
I'm gonna say
experiences not maybe interactions with
Satan or his minions his demons
limitations or whatever just talking
about like Temptation like being
believing lies there was a lot of uh
language and teaching around
um
you know
associating
things like that with an interaction
with the dark side with like
with with Satan right so it's okay I'm
not going to give in to the power of
Satan but
he's around so it's not like it's kind
of like I live in a ha yes Satan can be
here but I have this belief that through
Jesus I have power over Satan and not in
like a
uh Exorcist or vampire with a with a
cross kind of way not we didn't think
about it that way but we thought about
it in a very um
cerebral logical kind of way that's like
you know I didn't I didn't spend too
much time thinking about
Satan but if you press me I would say
yeah like I'm I'm supposed to
not listen to Satan not give in to
temptation
and I'm I can be delivered from Evil by
God right so
I think this level of proximity that we
believed in
you know it's like okay this this
experience makes sense but it's also
kind of safe and it doesn't have this
like Satan's Never Gonna or his demons
aren't gonna scratch me or send some
ghost afterwards and I was told many
times that hey you don't need to worry
about
demons uh like you don't need to worry
about being possessed because a demon
can't come into you because you're the
holy spirit's inside of you already
so that that was comforting but because
I think because of that it was like okay
I'm not gonna
I don't I'm not really interested in
Ouija boards because I know how Satan or
his whoever his minions are interact
with me in my everyday life and it's
just something that I've been able to uh
come to grips with and not be afraid of
and not dwell on but also not seek out
like that's the thing is that you don't
you don't want to start seeking this out
because then you're flirting with it as
like demonic activity as something that
could be fun it's the same reason that
we were too old for Harry Potter but
yeah we were on the fringes of that
movement that was like if we were
younger our parents wouldn't have
allowed us to read because of the
sorcery and I think my view was always I
think that if Satan you know existed and
at the time I definitely believe that he
did that he was super crafty and super
smart so it'd be like right what's more
strategic
and I would say it's more strategic for
Satan to have some sort of subtle
influence over this professor that I'm
going to this class and he is he is
causing me to doubt my worldview he's
causing me to doubt the truth of
Christianity the legitimacy of the
Resurrection or whatever like this
religion Professor is saying these
things that are challenging my world
view that guy is under the influence of
Satan and Satan is going to be much more
impactful in the World At Large if he's
working through Academia and so you end
up developing this view that the
principalities and the powers
of of Satan and his minions are not in
the Ouija board that you can get off of
the Shelf in Walmart they're in the
classroom you know they're in the places
they're in the places that we're
debating and defining culture
um they're changing with the times right
and and according to the old Rhett
the way that I changed and this is very
much the outspoken view of many people
who talk about me and you and from the
Christian Christian world is that we
fell to the vices of Satan that we are
and were and still are under demonic
influences and that's what's guiding us
at this point oh wow yeah well of course
what else is scariest story ever well
what else could it be
just somebody learning that it's
probably not true that doesn't make any
sense it couldn't just be that there's
also this like okay what of your own
sinful nature and like your selfish
inmost desires drive you so it's like
yeah yeah of course you know you know
also tended to own my faults as my own
more than I would say I gave in to the
temptation of some external satanic
Force like yeah we could have done it
all on our own without the influence of
Satan it just depends on what your you
know your take is I guess let's go back
to ghost hi my name's Ellie and I have a
somewhat spooky story per year Twitter
request
my grandmother haunts my entire family
it's just a fact it's not in any sort of
scary way she has a very distinct
perfume smell
um and anytime she wants to make her
presence known we all smell it it's come
up
when we're all together for holidays or
I don't know when something big happens
it came up most recently for me because
I got a tattoo in her husband my
grandfather's handwriting but yeah it's
more of a comforting haunting but
nonetheless a haunting
I hope you all have a great day bye well
that ain't gonna happen now after that
story I'm not having a great day with
your grandma just spraying perfume
perfume gives me a headache you know
this is probably the scariest story I've
heard today but you don't know if ghost
perfume that has the same sort of impact
Grandma ghost perfume is is gonna like
make my brain hurt I mean Jenna I I mean
I don't know if you ever think about the
awkward conversation we had about your
perfume but I think about it often what
do you remember about that conversation
uh we were on tour in Toronto oh okay
it was a little overcast I remember
exactly we were walking back from like a
lunch or a breakfast back to the hotel
before we had to uh you had your
performances that night and uh yeah you
we were walking along and and it was the
three of us maybe the three of us it was
the three of us and you're like hey
something about I can't remember exactly
how it started but you were just
basically like the perfume that you wear
sometimes it gives me a headache and I
was like okay uh it was Aqua de
Giorgio was or something I can never
pronounce how committed were you to this
perfume was this your scent
I I wasn't fully committed I mean it was
like if you died yeah and your family
wanted to know you were it wasn't like
this it wasn't me sprayed in the room it
wasn't your signature yeah I still have
it but I don't wear it around you
anymore
but I've worn other perfumes and you
haven't had that same reaction so
because if you know that I would tell
you if I did yes if it did bother you
just go ahead and tell me but yeah you
know wear other perfume and you haven't
made a comment if if I you know
if our interactions are it goes both
ways you know if they become defined by
something that like really gives gives
you a headache or a toothache or any
type of ache I would hope that you would
tell me like that's the community
communication climate that we have
created by me
just in the nicest way possible telling
you don't wear perfume around me full
stop full stop I think that the level I
didn't know you were wearing other
perfumes around me I feel kind of
betrayed but you're pushing your you
know what it's your
I thought I said no perfume but I'm just
joking now I said that one but that's
not really what I was thinking I was
thinking he only accepts like lotions
from Bath and Body Works that smell like
strawberry but you're right I haven't
you haven't given me a headache from the
way that you've smelled um since then
just a headache from how I talk to you
guys no
but I think that the level of perfume
that you wear during your life
because some people really go go real
real hard with how much fragrance they
put on and maybe if you have a very high
level and there's a saturation in your
skin that can pass through to the
afterlife and I believe I met someone
who this would be the case with
um
just this couple days ago I was a
going down to the bottom of my driveway
which is a hill to bring the trash cans
back up to the top of the driveway
and there was a young couple that was
getting into a car coming out of
someone's house and they got no closer
than
50 feet
50 feet
outside okay
and it was not windy
and I smelled this woman
uh or I smelled This Woman's perfume
it was so intense and as I ascended my
driveway
I I was setting the trash cans down
at the top of my driveway and could
still smell it well you got a you gotta
clear the nasal passages
you gotta blow out the only point I'm
making is that well hey uh I just feel
like that's overdoing it it's overdoing
it but uh B if that when that woman
becomes a ghost she'll be a smelly ghost
do you think like this Grandma this
grandma is it's just she smells strong
you don't think she's like spraying it
and trying to communicate oh you think
it's ghost perfume that she's like
coming in it
yeah that's kind of how I was thinking
well I think it's I think it's just
somehow got through it got through
I mean some form of you gets through
some form of your physical form right
the little girl was a little girl she
didn't the face didn't come the facing
the face was left behind me yeah she
didn't get to bring her face sometimes
things don't transfer but I think that
if you've saturated your epidermis with
this smell I think that the people can
cross over the people who make a
decision about what's important to you
they're like looking at the list and
they're like
smelling like this is important to this
lady let it let it through I think they
let the perfume through this is a cool
one though right because it's like it's
a it's a happy haunting like
I'm still here in a you know I'm I
haven't completely left
yeah
it doesn't sound like a rewarding
experience for the grandma though you
know it's like
or you don't know what it's like on the
other side
yeah I I really don't rep you don't know
what it's like do it really don't to
attend Thanksgiving as a ghost I mean it
might be horrible
it might be like man I wish I could eat
that turkey leg
or it might be like I have no taste for
turkey any longer
it's wonderful to see my former family
gather all right if if this is if this
is where you're going let's just let's
just go with one from the not as creepy
category because I just I'd like to
break it up hey Rhett and Link
um so my name is Jordan and I think you
guys might really like this one because
I know that you guys are fans of the
office and mine sort of revolved around
that so my spooky story is that when I
was about 13 or so I went
um with my family to Scranton and we
stayed at the Ukraine Radisson and we
just had a whole weekend where we
visited all locations that they
mentioned in the office
um really cool weekend except at the
screen Radisson
apparently there is a history there of
it being haunted and if you look up
pictures it definitely looks kind of
like
when it gets haunted and so
um I then got a little scared once we've
been and I realized that this place
probably haunted and I looked it up and
there were stories and anyways long
story short
um my mom is a medium and I asked her
and she said yeah no she definitely
picking up on some things so all night I
was terrified and when I woke up I was
like okay cool we did it you know we got
through the weekend and there was no
incidents and then of course right as
I'm about to leave I unplug my charger
from the wall and I swear to you my
fingers were not touching anything else
it was not touching the wall nothing was
sticking out
when I unplugged it my finger got cut
and really bad and was bleeding and it
just non-stop blood the whole way back
and I swear to you there's nothing
around nothing poking out so yeah that
was my story thanks guys appreciate it
so I appreciate you the Radisson ghost
um did dude cut his finger
his mom's a medium though
I don't know I don't know what to make
of this one it's still it almost seemed
as creepy as the other one I thought it
was in the not as creepy category but
like until the like the like the cut
part like it did kind of fizzle out
you know but that's a good idea for like
a family trip you know if everybody
watches the office
you know I prefer watching Survivor and
then going to Fiji but if you uh prefer
watching the office and going to
Scranton then that that can be your bowl
of chips you know what I'm saying but
they didn't film
in Scranton that I I don't know did they
film exteriors in Scranton I hope that
they did they filmed in La they filmed
most in LA but I guess they had
exteriors there you having fun you
liking this oh I'm loving it hi you guys
were looking for spooky stories yes
um scariest thing that ever happened to
me was
um I was babysitting or looking after my
parents house uh a few years back
and it was kind of getting towards later
in the evening on one day while I was
there and I just was kind of finishing
up my errands for the day so I decided I
was going to take out the trash
man was coming the next morning so felt
like was the right thing to do
um so I took the garbage out and I
remember very specifically on the way
out looking at the digital clock that's
next to the computer in the LA in the
living room as I was heading out and it
said it was 607 p.m and this is kind of
in the summer so it was light outside
still even though I was in the evening
um so took the garbage down to the end
of the driveway dropped it off walked
out to the house and activity that
shouldn't have taken no more than a
minute or two
and then all of a sudden when I close
the door I it's like I blinked and it
was Pitch Black outside and I went and
looked at the clock and it said it was
1207 A.M
as in just after midnight
um I like tour around the house checked
all the clocks all of them said the
exact same thing
and I still today have no idea what
happened during those six hours
um ended up calling a friend of mine
woke him up and I went and slept at his
house for that night because I was just
too freaked out
so yeah that was my terrifying story
what that's wild
I mean this feels like home alone like
taking the trash like nobody's at the
house
it's light
and then it's dark
I don't know if I would call a friend
after this I think I would go to WebMD I
know yeah you start to think like I had
a time lapse like did I I mean but she
didn't it's not like she like found
herself crumpled up on the floor like
coming to from
fainting or something well yeah I know
but I
I'd be freaked out I would Google it
from a friend's house after I'd left the
vicinity yeah
yeah I was thinking like what what
happened to him like what happens in my
brain that's a scary on a medical level
versus on a horror level kind of a thing
to me but if you lost six hours but this
is it this is this is every type of
horror movie that I would like to watch
yeah it's more psychological Thriller
like what happened to you in those six
hours
uh uh aliens potentially
because that is a that is a common thing
in
stories of alien abduction is completely
missed time
um I think vampires can also wipe your
memory
when they yeah they they suck your
memory out with your blood
um I don't know what it could be the the
strange perfume of a grandmother or a
neighbor well I don't I don't know and
what we do in the shadows they can
easily yeah that's what I was referring
to that's where I learned all my vampire
Knowledge from but like that's a good
that's a good story I mean it's one of
those things that like when it happens
to you yeah I mean she's had no other
symptoms since then obviously
it reminds me of the book The Midnight
Library
of I have read it yeah where you can
jump into another version of yourself to
see if that's the life you want to live
yeah so it's like a multiversal
yeah so maybe somebody assumed her life
for six hours a version of her assumed
her life for six hours and then and then
you suddenly and then decided they
didn't want it yeah so she just
concluded like oh my life's not good
enough to be taken over by another
version of myself yeah
okay it's a fascinating fact it's a
really good book yeah hmm
it's an adult book huh
um is it a children's book you're
talking about reading this recently or
it's an adult book yeah okay but young
adults could read it easy
yeah that's that's freaky
what about this one hey that link okay
so here is my
disturbing slash spooky experience so
some friends and I were driving home
from a concert and we live in Michigan
and we were driving home from Chicago to
Michigan
and it was pretty late and one of our
friends was asleep in the back seat and
then the three other of us were awake
and well obviously
and uh so we were just driving along and
we were all really tired and so when we
were driving I saw what looked to be
about a six and a half to seven foot
tall man slash dog walking alongside the
highway and I thought I was
hallucinating it and I said oh my God
I'm hallucinating and he goes my friend
who was driving goes no I saw that too
and our friend in the back seat the one
who was awake goes I saw it too it was a
dog man and we were all like holy [ __ ]
oh can I swear on here sorry our friend
who was sleeping woke up and was like
what what did we see and I was like you
didn't see anything
but yeah we've all been really freaked
out about it uh since then uh We've
looked it up and apparently there's
something called the dog man of Michigan
it's like um I never knew about it
before and so we looked it up but it's
it's a thing people see them
kind of crazy
well when you experienced something
oh she said bye guys that scared me like
the fact that it was a dog man bye guys
like I literally I thought it was hi
guys I literally got scared hi guys I
thought I was playing another I'm here
for your computer
um I mean when you get in this zone of
like being like exposed to this type of
stuff I'm going to go home tonight I'm
gonna put the trash cans back around in
the dark and I'm gonna do what I do when
I start thinking about these type of
things and I'm gonna have to run back in
the house like I'm on record saying I've
had to do it I'm gonna do it again after
this you ever take a bat or anything out
there I don't I love that
you think you think you think anyone
allows me to have weapons in my house no
there's nothing like a fire I don't even
have a fire poker like I have one of
those things where you can make s'mores
um I have a bat under my bed
I I I I have a bat that um he's made
for like hitting Intruders with
um that it's made out of like a
composite and it's really heavy and I
think it has a piece of metal inside of
it I think I get the one I got is too
too big like I feel like I you can't
wield it's a little too heavy but if I
catch you with it it's over man uh but
it's because it's not like a wooden bag
because if you hit somebody with a
wooden bat it'll break
um can you throw it because that means
you could it needs to have throwing
stars in the bottom of it but the thing
about this is again there's two other
people in the car and the first you know
she's like I'm hallucinating I love this
story this is this is my favorite
the number like everybody's like no I
saw something too I saw a dog man it's
like I saw a dog man and then it turns
out so there's corroboration within the
vehicle of I didn't tell you it was a
dog man I just said I hallucinated you
said it was a dog man and I agree and
then you start looking it up and there
is a dog man of Michigan
who that they didn't know about
beforehand okay like this is this is
really coming together I said that we
weren't going to do this but I have to
do it on this one because for me this is
the easiest one for me this one's not
scary to me because oh really yeah
because
there's somebody dressing up like a dog
man in Michigan like that's and I would
do this and I may do this in my older
years
assume a creepy identity of some sort of
creature and be seen in a state you know
you're large dude you are freaking yeah
well to think about it if you take like
an average sized dude you know six feet
tall and he put some sort of
headpiece head piece on that's a dog and
he puts on some like tattered clothing
he's like yeah I walk down the side of
the street here and then I have a little
place where I can go back into the woods
and people stop and you know it's fun
it's fun there is a risk to that guy's
um getting shot or something for real I
mean I I wouldn't do that that's really
high risk in that way I I think it would
be cool to do it
it'd be cool to know that you did it
oh to be friends with the dog man it'd
be cool to be friends with you dog man
so that like
I mean to do it for like
on and off for a month and then starting
to search online to see when people
started to talk about it that would be
fun but that's a long play we gotta come
out with my Persona because it can't be
Dogman because that's taken
uh I don't think you should do this
because I don't want you to get shot
because my other part of this is if you
were there
and it happened the way it happened
would you stop and turn around not
knowing that it was a dog man in
Michigan until later
hell yeah it's time to turn around I
don't know if you would I think you
would be too scared what I think you'd
be on the fence now if you if you were
going there to see the dog man in
Michigan like you were Ryan and Shane
doing an episode of uh ghost files of
course this is exactly what you wanted
you would turn around and you you'd be
going all through the woods filming
stuff and I yes I would be there
um I think I'm gonna watch that I'm
gonna walk the PCH but if you didn't
know so I'm right next to that I don't
know that you would stop and I'm
Barnacle Man and it's just a man it
looks like a dead dude covered in
barnacles
Barney the Barnacle Man that I mean I'm
not going to give Barney Barney cool and
I kind of like scrape along across the
bridges and stuff
Barnacle Man
of the PCH
I mean if you got shot then I don't I
don't think they would be you're less
likely to get shot in California for
being Barnacle Man than you are in
Michigan
well that's true you know what I'm
saying I'm definitely not doing it in
the south
um dear man lasted a week
this one is a California a California
one if you're talking about California
hey Rhett and Link My name is Janelle
I'm a long time listener first time
caller and I grew up in Camarillo
California you may have driven through
on your way to Santa Barbara or like
Ventura and
um we have California state Channel
Islands located in Camarillo which used
to be Camarillo state hospital
um and it's pretty done up these days it
doesn't look quite as run down
um but it's still pretty creepy and
growing up we used to go out there
around Halloween time and try and scare
ourselves and there's like an old dairy
because the hospital was self-sufficient
and that part is still super run down
and creepy there's a lot of urban
legends about the place
and yeah and I actually went to college
there as it was csuci
um and that was really creepy after late
classes you'd kind of see stuff you're
not supposed to see and it's you know
bars on the windows and everything
um and fun fact my great-grandpa died
there
so that makes it less scary for me
because it's just old Gramps hanging out
all right see ya
is it on one of the islands is that what
she said
no it's on the mainland and
Hotel California this song is about this
mental institution
huh I did that I've heard so many things
about Hotel California that it's like
there's probably there's I think there's
five other theories but like I don't
know if this is like an eagles Brian I'm
asking you if this is like a Eagles have
gone on record saying that
because it's like they don't know I've
heard there's a place in Mexico
said they went to Hotel California
that's cool
yeah it's the narrative that I
agree yeah the mental institution which
I don't know if they even call them that
anymore it's like that's a
I mean if I grew up there I could
definitely see
that and in like high school we would
have done that gone out there and like
begged each other on I'm really
surprised that we didn't
like as much as you're into this stuff
now you weren't quite and you like to
scare all of our friends like we were in
the camping in the woods and stuff like
that but we never got into this spooky
thing in the way that like nowadays it's
such a trend we didn't have the internet
we didn't have the internet you're right
and we did you know if you had to know
somebody who knew it
now
yeah we would have organized these kinds
of trips and there's multiple every
State's got them but there are multiple
like Legends in North Carolina about
lights and ghosts and stuff
you know I know and we just kind of
missed all of that
I feel sad for us but I'm kind of glad
at the same time
all right let's uh this look this one
looks interesting hey what's up guys I'm
calling for the spooky experience
so I was in fifth or sixth grade and my
dad took me to the Amazon uh for a canoe
trip and we had been down there for a
couple days we're canoeing we were
feeling the vibe and
one day we're canoeing some middle of
the day breaks on the day and I'm
canoeing along and we pass this
Riverbank
and what I see really freaked me out
it was a clown and I know clowns are
this like crazy thing now and people are
scared of clowns but it just wasn't
clown
wasn't doing anything spooky was just
standing there
um that's spooky
I I didn't know how to react so I I
looked to my dad and I'm about to tell
him but I see his face and his face
was I've never seen my dad scared before
and that's all I can describe it as and
I say to him I'm like
what's wrong what's wrong and he goes oh
I can't tell you I can't tell you
and I go tell me please just tell me
and he looks at me and goes I think I
saw a clown
we never talk about it we never asked
anyone about it we just kept going down
the river and so from this day on from
that day on me and my dad have this
strange clown in the Amazon story
then that's it how's it going happy
Halloween
that is
I mean that's freaky again it you could
make the dog man in Michigan
explanation here
it would be helpful to know like what
where on the Amazon they were
were they like in a dense
you know area where there was no towns
or or whatever I mean people
even though clowns are creepy people
still choose to be them
right you know there are people who are
just like clowns and I guess clowns got
to go to the river sometimes
and just stand well wouldn't you though
I feel like his arms were like totally
limp at his sides and he was motionless
well there was a club did turn you know
it was like that's the only thing it
moved was like his head and then his
smile got bigger like that's that's the
only thing that moved
there there was a clown that was going
around uh like his hands were really
heavy he stays pretty recent not
recently but in the last few years there
was a repeated clown sighting maybe in
L.A I don't know but this is I know it
was yeah I think about the people who
are like me and again I don't do this
because I don't have enough free time
uh and you know I really don't want to
put on the makeup in the costume
but I totally get the idea of I'm just
going to do this thing that's going to
freak people out and give people stories
that's exactly what that was it was I
think it was multiple people dressing up
like clowns and just being places and
it really started freaking out and
people and like they started to it was
like a
there was a rash of clown sightings and
it was it was uh you know it started
raising other questions about like okay
what are they after and yeah you know
and it could be an innocent prank but it
could also be something
yeah that's why you don't want to dress
up like somebody man I mean I wonder if
any of those clowns got
attacked
I don't think anybody would attack
Barnacle Boy
all right fine just
leave leave me out of it
let's wrap it up with this one hey guys
Brad here long time fan I love what you
guys do thank you
um this is in response to the spooky
story tweet that you guys put out there
so this one's a bit of a doozy uh I have
sleep paralysis occasionally and a few
years ago I would put that but this time
it's so different I like I thunk through
my bed through the floor and landed in
my kitchen is what it felt like
and I felt this tingling sensation
behind me and when I turned around there
was a giant black mass with a letter on
the table behind it so I approached the
letter and I open it
and it's empty there's nothing on it but
like Tom Riddle's Diary in Harry Potter
the letters being written in real time
in front of me and for the sake of the
story I'm going to use the name Rebecca
but the letter said Thank you for taking
care of Rebecca
I really appreciated all the people in
Rebecca's alike here are pretty poorly
but you're the only person that actually
takes care of her so thank you love
Rebecca's grandmother
and then in that moment when I finish I
got floated up through the floor again
landed in my bed and shot up and and gas
for air it was just so crazy for the
next thing I contacted Rebecca and I
said this might sound weird but I think
I was visited by your grandmother in my
sleep and Rebecca responds with
that's not weird at all my grandmother
visits me in my sleep all the time and
then I said she left me a thank you
letter
what do you think that has to do with
anything and Rebecca said that her
grandmother left letters for anybody and
it didn't matter if they invited her
over for dinner they would get a thank
you letter and when she sent me a photo
of an existing letter it was the same
handwriting as in my dream and I'm not
joking it was insane
um but anyway I hope that's a good one
and uh Happy Halloween everybody
oh God
oh my God hey that was Brian said leave
that one for last but it was a good one
again I I think that the moral here is
that ghosts can be good if they're
grandmas
yeah especially Grandma ghosts man
you ask that crazy you've had sleep
paralysis that's scary in and of itself
right but I've never seen uh lots of
people see the black figure like the
black mass
uh and
like there's a name for it like the
sleep paralysis demon or something like
that I haven't had it in many years but
I used to have it all the time as a kid
and a teenager and then into my 20s but
it's probably happened once or twice in
the past 15 years but it's never been
scary on like a supernatural level or
I've seen anything it's just makes me
very scared for my like safety like am I
gonna be stuck like this you're not
thinking straight in the moment because
you're like half awake
but I've definitely never been
transported to a kitchen and read
somebody's Grandma's note to get a thank
you letter from a ghost written in real
time
that's pretty cool man it's pretty cool
talk about feeling validated for
something you did
yeah that's better than a trophy or a
metal or like a ribbon that you wear
around your neck ghost letters I mean
Christie's parents told her that like
don't do anything you shouldn't do with
your boyfriend because your dead
Grandma's watching like that's literally
what they told her and it worked yeah
like Christy said it worked and it was
like this is kind of corroboration you
know it's like Grandma what is Grandma
scene
you know with a letter she could write
about me
you know I I'm just grateful that my you
know my nanny didn't pass away until I
was a I was uh you know an adult
I thought about this many times as a
teenager just first of all I'm grateful
that my nanny didn't pass away until
when she did because I love my nanny uh
but I guess as a like a correlation
I would also not want any
nannies watching me and the stuff that I
well but this is the thing
grandmas no
that people masturbate grandmas know and
so I mean I thought I wasn't just
thinking about I thought about this as a
masturbating teen uh who had a dead
grandmother
and I was like if my ancestors including
my grandma granny was her name can see
me doing this it's just like well she
could also look away you know because
she could see any she could choose to
see anyone masturbating and everywhere
she's gonna look she's gonna see a uh
some somebody masturbating yeah but when
all of your ancestors are gathered
around
watching you masturbate if granny looks
away she's gonna feel like the peer
pressure of like I think Don't Look Away
granny again going back to the ghost
orientation I think like page two is
like let's talk about masturbation
you're gonna see a lot of it and you
didn't see a whole lot of it in your
Waking Life but this is pretty much this
is going to Define your afternoon it's
like you're gonna see so much whacking
off that you're it's gonna you're gonna
become completely desensitized to it and
you're going to see your grandkids
whacking off okay it's just part of the
deal and then people any questions it's
like do I have to look it's like you
know you don't have to look but you
might as well start looking because it
does it everyone does it guys
I mean I thought about this as a kid and
and I got over it very quickly
it's a good idea for a show I mean it's
like
basically what you just pitched was like
the ghost version of what we do in the
shadows like the way they approach
the World of Vampires it's like what how
does this practically play out from the
ghost perspective you know all right
let's make that TV I'm sure it's been
done but like I would love to see them
do it and let's go around town and pitch
that TV show and be told why no one will
let us make it let's do that that's fun
no we don't do that but I I do think the
more I think about it I think there was
a a New Zealand based show that was a
companion show to um what we're doing
the Shadows well we're doing the Shadows
that's more of like Paranormal I thought
there was a they were doing a werewolf
spin-off I think they're doing that too
so anyway I'm pretty sure it already
already exists because I've watched one
episode it was just really hard to
understand them
and I didn't know how to turn subtitles
on yet can't remember what it's called
but
um okay for us yeah I got a wreck for us
especially
if you want to like cleanse your brain
of like all this scary stuff so that
when you take out your trash you don't
have to Sprint back in like there's a
happy place that I now find myself going
to a lot on tick tock
so this is a tick tock recommendation
uh Jewel the artist known as Jewel the
Canadian blonde woman you know who's who
sang the songs in the 90s she loves Tick
Tock and she's got a great sense of
humor she tells some great stories she
will go on Hikes and she will show you
amazing Vistas
and she has catch phrases I think her
main catchphrase is something to the
effect of
would you get a load of the [ __ ]
that I got going on today like this is
what she says she's like and uh you know
her teeth are perfectly imperfect like
she's decided that that's not something
she's ever going to change about herself
and I love her for it like I'm saying I
mean she's a beautiful person inside and
out
and it's just like she's she make she
she'll make you happy in like a like I
would love to be her friend
like I'm not saying I have a crush on
her it sounds like you are which is fine
I think I do have a crush on her but I
also would I really just want to be your
friend like I really want to go on a
hike with her
um and sometimes if she's on tour like
she doesn't seem like she has any
friends because you never see anybody in
her videos except for her
but she you know she takes ice baths she
tells stories of like growing up and
wherever the hell she's actually from
Alaska right
yeah but she had I think she was talking
about like her uncle who's like from
Iceland
she tells funny stories about her
relatives like that
there it is man follow Jewel on tick
tock
you're welcome uh thank you for all your
sort your stories your your call in very
fun very fun I'm not gonna sleep well
tonight thanks to you hashtag ear
biscuits let us know what you think 188
earpod one
okay here's my spooky story
I know a lady and she had a vacuum
cleaner I was trying to borrow a shop
vac and we were looking in the shop in
her shed for the shop vac and her
husband had recently died we could not
find the hose for the vacuum and a voice
from nowhere whispered in my ear look
inside and I said hey I think Jim is
telling us to look inside and sure
enough she looked inside the vacuum and
there was the hose
that's my story hey uh my name is Justin
I was not a big believer in the
Supernatural until one night while I was
in bed with my ex-wife who I now believe
to be personally legitimately haunted I
woke up to a screen from her and I saw a
guy like half sort of bent over our bed
and he was there and then gone all of a
sudden
uh we compared notes later on and we
either had the craziest shared dream or
something was there with us and this is
just one of like a few instances that
led me to believing in the things that I
do now thanks for listening I love you
hey guys this is Jamie I'm actually on a
paranormal team and I've had a couple
but my favorite was I was sitting at a
local haunted attraction when I heard a
whisper that said we're coming Jamie
which is my name and then everything on
my rear view mirror started to blow as
if the wind was blowing on it but there
was no Breeze there was no one around
then we got home and the lights turned
on in our apartment so we had to do a
cleansing because it was pretty
terrifying to watch more ear biscuits
click on the playlist on the right to
watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe if you prefer
to listen to this podcast it's available
on all your favorite podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best
[Music]